uh uh wow
aiuto
ok
potente Non svegliare Luca cattivo Ah
Guardatela c'è il nuovo nonno Cattivo
che sta dormendo e noi dobbiamo provare
a Non svegliarlo e riuscire a scappare
dalla sua casa infatti questo è una
nuova Skin con il nonno cattivo grempa
lasciate un bel mi piace Mettetevi
comodi prendete i Popcorn e iniziamo
subito questa nuova Escape Room andiamo
a rubargli le cose da mangiare eh non ci
sono cose da mangiare Guarda c'è una
dentiera e un teschio che sono le
persone che hanno provato a scappare ma
non ci sono riuscita Infatti noi
metteremo la difficoltà normale Guarda
qua per terra c'è una mia foto con il
caffè sopra
io vedo la mia foto No io vedo la mia
foto fai vedere È vero vero scemo
comunque c'è scritto il mio nipote
preferito
fantastico Qual è il contrario di
preferito preferito favorito il mio
nipote è peggiore insomma
Oh ma nonno sei cattivissimo
Guarda quanto è brutto
anzi i peli del naso escono fuori dal
naso e poi agli occhi storti e i peli
nelle orecchiette Mamma mia
Anzi no cinque è uno due tre quattro
bruttissimo vediamo che cosa sto
guardando e infatti
vediamo
Ehi hai cambiato canale Wow può cambiare
canale
mettiamogli un film horror No no no
scherzo
dal 92esima competizione annuale delle
caramelle dure Eh
ho capito forse perché siccome lui ha la
dentiera non riesce a mangiare le
caramelle cioè quelle dure riesce a
mangiare solo le caramelle quelle
morbide e Però lui è riuscito a mangiare
la caramella più grande è un po' strana
così non so perché ci sono queste cose
qua ad esempio c'è un camino dovrebbe
esserci il fuoco la legna invece ci sono
delle sbarre c'è un LED qua c'è la luce
LED verde qua ha messo i nipoti quelli
che gli piacevano di meno li abbiamo
messi a cuocere qua la dentiera a cui
mancano dei denti e poi delle prugne
Vabbè vediamo
le prugne le caramelle dure Hehe andiamo
a ritratto familiare del nonno Allora
c'è il video poi c'è questa non mi
sembra la nonna Forse la nipote e poi ci
sono altri due nipoti che sono uguali al
nonno Ma rimpiccioliti se vedete giusto
certo
nonno sappi che ti sconfiggeremo
riusciremo a passare queste Escape Room
Ma tu continua a dormire Comunque Ahó si
è svegliato il nonno mi stai seguendo mi
sta chiamando sta dormendo Ho preso il
nonno mi ha preso questo perché decidi
di andare avanti senza di me e provare a
superarmi Così impari si è svegliato
Eccolo Mamma mia che brutto dobbiamo
scappare Meno male è lento Perché hai il
bastone Non toccare mai OK riproviamo
questa volta non mi prenderai nonno Sei
una schiappa sei troppo lento
che ha fatto t'ha preso No stavo
sentendo come parlava
e Ma tu dove sei nel frattempo sono
avanti Sono già davanti Ciao Aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
no
E poi ti guarda Guardate ci sono le
dentiere con la
bavarese
Ecco sta inseguendo un altro giocatore
attento però non inciampare nell'acqua
aiuto Ti vedo ce la puoi farcela Dimmi
che non passa da qua No no non passa
però devi andare più avanti vai ciao
ciao nonno con la dentiera oh oh oh Dio
perfetto Ehi vi piace il mio outfit
natalizio tutto rosso con il fiocchetto
anche se c'è un po' di freddo in effetti
veramente ma su Roblox
ah ah ciao ciao nonno andiamo e ora Uh
che bello aiuto ci sta guardando dal
quadro
del nonno sono orribili
e che schifo Guardate ah ah ah ah ah ah
C'è una foto proprio dei peli dal naso
dal nonno Ma che schifo guarda Si può
cliccare Oh che cosa sono broccoli
questo Escape ma veramente strana
sentiero e broccoli peli del naso questi
sono cavoletti di bruxelle quelle che
puzzano tantissimo
queste cose Esatto
Sulla cucina che c'entrano i laser sulla
cucina non ho capito è per cucinarci e
mangiarci sicuramente a tema i broccoli
ma lui guarda lì lo vedi là dietro
dietro broccoli per mangiarci dobbiamo
rubargli la dentiera così non riuscire a
mangiarci forse no Prima sfracellamento
no non è vero perché prima mi ha preso
il nostro a volte eh eh eh E voi avete
lasciato un bel mi piace ehm cliccate mi
piace qua sotto se non volete essere
colpiti dal broccolo Hahaha non volete
avere la dentiera anche voi cliccate mi
piace aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto Non
voglio essere
sfracellata da un broccolo
via via
via Uh Per un pelo visto che passavi in
mezzo al broccolo Allora il nonno qui ha
il pavimento e lava Uhm Okay
troviamo sempre il pavimento in lava Ma
l'ha messo apposta per noi forse boh per
cuocerci meglio magari un mattarello in
mano oh oh oh forse quella è la sua mano
a forma di Mattarello Ma quanto è brutto
mamma mia oh
Allora Scrivetemi nei commenti visto che
nell'altra Escape Room quella del
supermercato vi abbiamo chiesto qual è
il vostro frutto preferito ora
scriveteci nei commenti la vostra
verdura preferita e non diteci che non
vi piacciono le verdure perché sennò ci
arrabbiamo perché noi
eravamo troppo le verdure
diciamo qual è la nostra verdura
preferita è che ce ne sono talmente
tante che mi piacciono che non saprei
quale scegliere allora io adoro i funghi
i broccoli i pomodori e i fagiolini
e le patate ovviamente vero soprattutto
fritte Eccomi qua le salta tutte tutte
tutte Qual è la tua verdura preferita
sicuramente i funghi le patate la
cicoria Eh
tutto tutto tutto tutto e qua ci sono i
vestiti del nonno da casa sono più
grandi delle magliette
emotivamente Chissà perché sono in
vantaggio sono in vantaggio riuscirò a
battere Anita Arriverò prima io no
arriverò prima io veramente tanto di
sopraccelli Adesso chissà lo stendino
del nonno Vedi ci sono i pantaloni o
pesi e via di prugne No non fattoria
fabbrica la fabbrica di prugne di prugne
sotto casa vedi è buono succede se
prendiamo questa pulsante Ok
figo vediamo com'è fatta questa fabbrica
di prugne ma è stupendo Slime Slime Uh
sta volando e alla fine l'escape Room
come sempre voto da 1 a 10 scrivetecelo
nei commenti Anche noi vi daremo il
nostro voto Eccovi tale sorge la luna
piena
Allora dici di usare queste travi per
passare Vediamo iniziamo Ciao Ok ho
capito Io userò il trucchetto che mi ha
insegnato Vitale invece di tornare
indietro a prendere tutte le altre travi
Sì quindi ora passo poi la riprendo poi
la metto qua tac è molto più veloce fare
così ormai ci sono io che ti do questi
trucchetti
e qua c'era Luca mi stavo sfrecciando
attento non cadere nel succo di prugna
Anche perché sapete che effetto fa
mangiare troppo bruniere quest'anno
Quindi anche se ne mangia
allora Che effetto fa Ah ok Questo forse
non ci serve più Non lo so io per
sicurezza me la porto fino a sopra ma è
un po' scomodo salire Con questa trave
in mano no magari possiamo tirarla in
testa al mondo
perché
sei sotto io sono sopra già ciao ciao
ciao
finalmente arrivare così in fretta
Tesoro ciao ciao Sì sì
che figo ma c'è ancora un sacco di di
Escape Room qui Wow Ecco il succo di
prugna che esce dalla fattoria fabbrica
Volevo dire eh Esatto io provo a salire
qua sopra bello Ho preso la scorciatoia
Ciao Non ci credo un succo di frutta
esatto
prima che mi perdo qui in questa
labirinto Ah ecco perché mi stavi
aspettando perché tu ti perdi dei
labirinti Allora qui sembra ci sia una
discesa
è tutto cazzo di robot poi finisce
sempre che rotoliamo e ci sbattiamo
dappertutto
i biscotti i biscotti appena cotti
lo sto mangiando sono diventato gigante
sono caduto mi sono sfracellato lì non
lo so che cosa posso Sono diventata
gigante che bello professoressa
Ora prendo un altro biscotto
Uau Ok adesso si corre come hai fatto
super divertente eh
Ogni volta che faccio un passo mi
flacello devi stare attento e devi
saltare al momento giusto
speriamo di rimanere così giganti così
potremo affrontare ancora meglio il
nonno vero
ora aspettiamo Vitale e vediamo il rutto
di Vitale
Ehi Portami un biscotto Ok così riesco a
tornare gigante
No mi sono spaventata
è caduta
giusto Ecco Vitale La Lucciola farà
questa volta secondo voi ce la farà
vediamo
mi piaceva la super velocità Adesso
andiamo piano di nuovo
ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao
no aspetta Ma quando salti perché non mi
fa arrivare un Uffa No qui ho scoperto
qualcosa di sensazionale che cosa la
stanza della prugna dorata No La Stanza
della Musica
la vedo la vedo La andrò a prendere
Allora fammi vedere
Eccolo l'abbiamo fatto te lo dico
dobbiamo affrontare il nonno c'è un
bazooka Quindi no non mi dire questi
sono dei teschio dobbiamo fare
dentro sta dentro una specie di come si
chiama aiuto Mi sta perdendo non ce la
faccio a combattere Io nel frattempo ho
preso se riesco a trovare qualche arma
segreta Infatti il ragno gigante e c'è
anche un laser Oh yeah Sei riuscita a
sconfiggerlo
aiuto dai lo devi colpire Ti do un
consiglio vieni qua
dentro un robot con i ragni ritorna
indietro l'ho colpito da qui è facile
colpirlo aiuto
Vai via ragno gigante
Che brutto
Aiuto no ti ha preso
riproviamo questa volta si sconfiggerò
Prima
devo prendere la prugna d'Oro prima eh
tutto scompare
Ok prendiamo la prugna d'oro
questa volta si sconfiggerò nonno
prova stai andando benissimo aiuto Meno
male ho la super velocità altrimenti non
ce l'avrei mai fatta
Beccati questo Beccati questo
manca poco meno male non è velocissimo è
un po' lento l'hai preso ce l'hai fatta
titola per sempre magari riesco Ciao
Vi ricordate il bazooka che lanciava a
panini
se non avete visto vi lasciamo la
casellina alla fine di questo video per
vedere quelle super perché era troppo
divertente
vedo una Anita gigante l'avete
Oh ci stai seguendo ci stai seguendo il
nonno Uh Io pensavo non ci potesse
prendere anche qua è riuscito a scappare
dal Ragno meccanico aiuto
Mi sta inseguendo
superato e poi sono prontissima
quando sta per prendermi
mamma mia Va bene ti ha preso così forte
riesco ad arrivare primaria ha preso
anche te come ti ho detto Ma dove siamo
finiti
Uffa
No dobbiamo cercare veloce veloce veloce
militare nome no no no
oh oh Ma com'è che tu sei davanti e io
son dietro
Aiuto aiuto devo prendere il badge prima
di evitare forse ce la farò ma se io
sono avanti Non vedo niente c'è la testa
pelata dal divano Non vedo niente e poi
ce la sto facendo Che cosa dice aiuto
verso la libertà Dov'è il nonno Meno
male Qui abbiamo visto che figo
fighissimo
questo scherzo
[Musica]
È come tutto Viola non vedo niente
Vedo solo che c'è Anita gigante là sopra
ok ho trovato un trucco saltare
sull'acqua Sì sì ci siamo quasi Anita Ci
siamo quasi devo prendere
e ora dobbiamo salire in questa sorta di
Castello
Wow
la prendono prima io vai via invece
davanti tu non ci credo Speriamo che
cada Vitale io non devo cadere
altrimenti dovrò rifare così è finita Oh
no io sono caduto
tutta vita
ma ti pare che dobbiamo scalare la
montagna però
Eccomi sono arrivato Ho preso Belgio
prendiamo gli effetti Super salto
e super velocità Uh uh uh
e quanto tempo
meglio gli do un
nove e mezzo se fosse stata più lunga
con più livelli e avrei dato un 10 e tu
nove e mezzo io È troppo divertente Oh
yeah Facciamo un tuffo fiume di prugna
No nel mare
no non ci vedo più niente aiuto
Aiuto Ho toccato il
fondotinta Allora vogliamo
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
eh Buona visione Ciao